Harvard researchers made an incredible
discovery they have found a handwritten
eighteenth-century parchment copy of the
Declaration of Independence that they
didn't even know about the only one like
it is the original at the National
Archives in Washington now this copy was
found in Chichester England buried in
the archives of a records office Charlie
d'Agata is inside that office with what
this discovery could tell us about our
country's founding moments charlie good
morning good morning up from the
archives and now here just for us the
Declaration of Independence in great
condition
considering its age and despite what
we're told is a mouse having taken a
nibble out of it at some point now if
this is what it is it is a major find in
an unlikely place one historian called
it the discovery of a lifetime a
priceless handwritten parchment of the
Declaration of Independence beyond rare
the only one like it is the 1776 copy
kept under the glass at the National
Archives in Washington we certainly
weren't looking for a copy of the
Declaration like this Harvard
researchers Emily snap and professor
Danielle Allen came upon it while
searching the globe for every known copy
of the Declaration nobody even had an
inkling that a second one might exist
and so therefore there was no reason to
look for such a thing they believed it
was penned in America in the 1780s
probably commissioned by James Wilson
I'll be the man who prevented American
independence portrayed is a flip-flopper
in the movie 1776 but a fervent
nationalist and there is a difference in
this copy that drills down into the very
foundation of the nation the signatures
are in no particular order rather than
listed by state as in the 1776 copy the
ghost of the heart of the American
political order does the American
political order rest on a single
national people or on treaties among
several states the researchers believe
the document originally belonged to the
Duke of Richmond known as the radical
Duke for the support he gave to American
revolutionaries it was handed down over
generations of dukes until
man handed it in to the records office
in the 1950s is this gonna stay here
Conti archivist Wendy Walker makes no
excuse for sitting on it for 60 years we
didn't know we had it but as I say it
hadn't had the academic interest and
research done on it to to bring out any
of the any of the detail considering its
historical magnitude it hadn't been
treated well it even been folded into a
small square but for Emily's snap it was
a thing of beauty Oh being able to go to
s Sussex and hold this parchment in our
hands to look at it closely was just
extraordinary
we're told the British Library will be
conducting a series of tests over the
summer to determine its authenticity and
while people are invited to come have a
look if they want there are no
intentions of putting this Declaration
of Independence on display Nora Wow
Charlie d'Agata in England thinks that
is awesome oh no a second cup a second
copy and it's in good condition that's
very nice but that founders never
disappointed yeah all the surprises